and I think I've I've chased
opportunities to make money which have
been fleeting they've been profitable
but fleeting and I think when you're in
your 20s you should do those frankly you
should just do the things that are like
hot and exciting if you think want to
make money and then in your 30s you
start reflecting more like Wow mortality
is real what's really important and I
think you'll come back to finding how do
I work on problems and things that I
want created for in my own world
know what's going on sampar um in
meetings all day and I'm heading out to
California in four hours so I was just I
haven't been on this podcast in a minute
because I was in Austin I drove from
California to Austin I hung out with
Noah Neville and a bunch of people and
now Noah is coming to Malibu or I'm
coming to SF for a month and then I'm
gonna go to Malibu for a month where are
you staying in San Francisco Andrew
Chen's house oh that's right you told me
I I've decided that I'm gonna get rid of
my apartment in San Francisco and I'm
gonna live in different cities for one
or two months each I we're copying each
other Sam you went bald so I went bald
you're I'm moving places so you're
moving places I need to get glasses a
dog yeah well yeah you know uh I need a
few things your funding we we know each
other well but can you tell the
listeners who you are what is up you
sexy listeners Noah Kagan I'm a cyclist
I'm a chess player lately I'm making a
lot of content on YouTube about
everything I'm learning at appSumo calm
that's youtube.com slash okay dork I
helped start appSumo Khan which is the
number one site online for software
deals and hate figure company been
around ten years I was number 30 at
Facebook number four at mint calm and
then the two other things that I like
working on and playing with
business-wise ascend fox.com which is a
free email list for content creators and
okay dr. calm which is my said about
overcoming fear starting and marketing
startups and no one I have known each
other for six or seven years oh wow now
we're you're well I think you're five or
six years older than me
we're very similar personalities we're a
little crazy we have a bunch of
different ideas would you say that's
accurate yeah I didn't like you for a
long time
why so sometimes you'll hang out with
Sam if you guys have hung out or had the
chance to you know the same he's like
how much what are you making doing this
one thing and it's like
it's like someone asked you like how big
is your like dude I don't know you and
you're asking a really personal kind of
aggressive it's almost it's like to the
level of transactional that's just a
little too much versus what you'd expect
from a friend and I think sometimes it's
interesting to observe the people or
companies that were jealous of or the
companies were reacting negatively
negatively to and really trying to
understand that and our first experience
I think if I recall you wanted me to
come speak at the hustle no III what it
was yeah I wanted you to speak at an
event and I you asked me to write a blog
post for you and I wrote this blog post
and then you didn't publish it and I was
like what the [__]
there was just weird vibes I was getting
from you and so it didn't make me
excited to want to do anything and then
you sent me like a nutribullet or some
kind of item and I was just like this
guy weirds me out I don't like how he's
behaving and so over the years though
I've started to appreciate your
quirkiness and it's probably like me I'm
sure some people listening to me with
like I don't like the style
I think the point for everyone is not to
just go and accept everyone and love
everything but to observe our jealousy
observe a negativity observe our
criticism and think about what we're
trying to really say about it ourselves
or learn about ourselves I think one
thing I would say about you Sam that
I've appreciated is that it's
interesting to observe the people in
life who get what they want
because those people you don't see all
the things they're not getting and I
really respect with Sam how persevering
you are I think there's a lot of times
where I'm like oh yeah this guy is gonna
go there's so many people I'm like oh
they're gonna quit soon and I definitely
you know the hustle wouldn't be anything
without effort and I think without you
just kept going and won't stop and I
think more people have to some people
like well I don't have that I'm not
saying power or not no kickin I'm not
it's like yeah you're yourself which is
even better and it's just finding the
things that you'd never want to give up
on so find your hustle find your appSumo
find your okay dork calm and just find
something you'll never quit on and then
go for it that's one thing I definitely
appreciated watching your journey from
afar you said you didn't like me or I
rub you the wrong way were you saying
that begin then you said jealousy you're
saying because you think I was jealous
of you or you jealous of me or not at
the time I just found you kind of I was
uncertain of your motive I did it
spinning like six years so I'm not just
exact
sure I don't you know I do have I do
spend most of my days thinking about you
hmm I think everyone's favorite story is
themself so if you ever want to talk to
someone be like hey you know what I
noticed about you and they're like what
but I think feedback is a whole nother
thing we can talk about that I think I
just had a weird vibe and I didn't know
what your intentions were and I think
what was interesting is like other
friends of ours were like oh yeah he's a
good dude
and he is but I was like I guess I'm
missing something so let's uh we're
gonna talk about business in a second
and I think this is kind of an
interesting conversation because but I
think that what has brought us to be
friends is our mutual friend novel
Medora who is both of ours best friend
he was the best man at my wedding and
you have a wall you have a brother but
he probably had it not been for your
brother he probably would be in that
category for you as well and so it's
interesting how like like you could we
both see how we're loyal to one person
and that brings like good qualities out
of each other I think Neville said I'm
his number one I know if you talked to
him recently well we can fight over that
what he says in bed to both of us he's
like no I never said he said I was ever
one but I know we both we're both loyal
to similar people so let's talk about
let's talk about different interesting
companies and businesses that we're both
looking at because we're you and I are
the same and that we're both like pretty
big schemers and not that we do [__] all
the time but we both like like like to
figure out how things work what are you
looking at like you're really interested
in the email space with sin Fox I'm
interested in that as well what what
interests you about email like why are
you like cuz AB sumos pretty successful
you don't have to start new [__] if you
didn't want to why are you choosing sin
Fox I think choosing it one of my
favorite books around the words that you
use is the dali lama's art of happiness
and i love that you were chose alright
because i don't have to do anything I
want to do things I don't need to do
stuff I want stuff and I think it's
interesting for all of us to be aware of
that
and it must stay everyone I think what
in my life I think one of the things
that drives me is curiosity and I think
in terms of business like if people out
there you know listen to this and say
hey I want you my business started the
best business to start is something that
solves your own problem
and so for me I was using MailChimp I've
used convertkit I've checked out Aweber
check one I found him way over expensive
I found him way over complicated to me
like 45 minutes to set up MailChimp
email and so I was like I just want
something more affordable and simpler
and that's where we built Sun Fox and I
think that's something where I'll keep
working on it forever with the team I
think what's interesting is trying to
think about what's gonna happen in the
next six months to six years and then
how do I be a little bit ahead of
everyone else so if you think about it
let me ask you soon do you think there's
gonna be more or less content creators
in the future absolutely more so I think
you know the one problem that I notice
with all the channels like YouTube or
Instagram or tic toc or any of these is
that ultimately they are incentivized to
get you to pay to talk to your audience
why because they have to make money and
so email is the only channel I've ever
found that can scale communicating with
an audience that you can fully control
and so I think if San Fox becomes the
number one place of people to grow their
audiences one I want it for myself
number one and two is just a really big
and interesting opportunity to work on
so we send how many emails do I send a
year maybe six or seven hundred million
I don't even know to be honest I'm
appSumo probably has a similar amount of
emails like hundreds of millions of
sends per year well I pay I think I pay
10 or 15 grand a month to send those is
it done right I don't really know I
think what there's two things that are
more interesting to me one I've been
focusing more on the total audience that
you have available because email isn't
is a component of your audience right so
you actually have like hustle on
Facebook hustle Instagram hustle YouTube
hustle podcast and your total active
audience and there's overlap that number
I'm actually more fascinated with and
the second thing with email I think the
metric cost is one thing but I think
though you said said [__] you said said
Fox was trying to make it cheaper
because you're more affordable I don't
like the portable yeah Laura for you
yeah because you're not seen how much is
that to cost ascend I like for us really
it I'll tell you if you take point zero
zero zero two and then times about how
many emails so the thing that MailChimp
and convertkit and all these guys so
point zero zero two times your number so
they make money if you don't send emails
because they make money off your
subscriber of course and so the way
that's so send fox is free and then
we're a one-time payment because most
people don't actually email and so we're
trying to fix that and work through
those kind of challenges with people but
the other thing I think people need to
think about in terms of growing their
community you're starting a newsletter
like if you don't have one start it
today you send fox comm number one but
the second thing is the number that's
the most important is not your email
list size it is your active email a size
so it is the amount of people within
three months that have opened and
clicked your email because you know I've
had hundreds of thousands from I think
in my total lifetime of okay dork I've
had a hundred and seventy-five thousand
subscribe to the newsletter my active
audience is only 55 think about that
yeah and that's what we do too but we
turn people every three months like we
sunset them like when we send them an
email be like hey you're gonna get we're
gonna take you off this list what
percentage is it I don't know off the
top of my head to be honest with you but
I know that like one I could tell you
this though so like our open rates
really really high right now it's like
55 percent and I think the average
person saves two years so you could
somehow figure out what that is yeah but
but like like if we don't get them on
the hook right away then they're never
gonna get on the hook how do you gonna
hook your welcome email needs to be
really good your Thank You page after
they sign up need to be really good you
know this [__] this is what you did good
dude here's the thing I'm still learning
well you had this root even your
unsubscribe page needs to be great which
you didn't you have a really good
unsubscribe path but I gave up on that
one I think the Thank You page and
you're welcome thing are like the two of
the most neglected pieces of marketing
yeah I call them like you have to make
the Forgotten parts really good so like
your Thank You page your welcome email
your unsubscribe page just like little
Easter Egg [__] like that it needs to be
good but to make them good yeah well are
so I get accused of stealing CD babies
email welcome email which I didn't even
know what that was but then when I saw
it I realized oh yeah I can I totally
understand why people see this
steal that stole that but my welcome
email was a like a really detailed
welcome email that it was like really
long and explained what happened when
you signed up and it was pretty funny
and like if your Google like the hustle
welcome email a lot of people wrote
about it people seem to like that so
just like being creative and writing
long-form content about what happened
after those types of things when those
people signed up it works pretty well
but with so let's say like convertkit
let's say convertkit is doing twenty
million dollars a year in sales which
converts awesome because i like the guy
who started it I like convertkit and
they reveal all their revenue numbers if
they're doing twenty million in revenue
like you said that you try to make cent
fox more affordable I have no idea how
much do they actually charge think - or
how much are they what's their cogs in
order to send all those emails Oh point
zero zero - it might be Oh point zero
zero zero one five times how many
subscribe how many emails are sending a
month the profit is all in the people
who don't email it's basically I think
of email marketing companies is very
expensive hosting you're basically
paying a lot of money to host zeros and
ones and digits that don't cost anything
and so I think more importantly if
people are businesses like that's a
really interesting business to start
it's also interesting business to
disrupt like I think sub stack has done
amazing with it coming at it from like
hey email is actually free and we're
gonna make money on the subscription
part so you don't have to pay for email
anymore
same with sin Fox it's like it's mostly
free and we're gonna be focusing we're
focusing more on like youtubers and
podcasters so it's like who are the
audience's that aren't really emailing
enough or don't know how to email for
this specific type of audience I think a
market for that is musician spans I
think there's a few like if you look at
them money where musicians make it is in
concerts and they're horrible at
notifying you when they're coming into
town well if you already type it type in
right now I was typing some note dude
relax but yeah I think musicians I mean
I think the point though you have to
serve a customer that I think you have
an understanding of I think a lot of
these want renews out they're like oh
yeah let me go help musicians I'm like
one I don't know [__] about musicians
I'm learning to play piano it's right
here but the point being is like I think
we it's not that you shouldn't go
outside of your comfort zone I
think there's easier ways of success and
I think more too many people make it too
hard on themselves and it's just like
going to your own problems or go into
problems of people around you that you
have easier access to what about have
you been looking into amp for email yeah
some of this stuff I mean I also you
know there's also talk about any emails
dying and all this stuff I'm like people
are using it left and right I've seen
amp where it's like a little bit more of
dynamic and faster loading emails I
think the most important thing about
email is not necessarily the layouts and
all that stuff I think the most
important thing is how do you build a
relationship where people are expecting
your email
we're like if I stopped emailing or the
hustle didn't come they're like
something is wrong with my day and until
you could spit that point you're you're
probably worrying about the wrong
problems yeah I mean that's the hard
part
obviously that's like how do you create
I mean that's just about creating good
[__] but I still think the whole amp
thing is actually super interesting what
what I'm working on is a few ways to
hack it because I kind of am obsessed
with like storytelling in email and so
what can you like if you think about
what is a Jif to me a jiff is a moveable
image that has no sound well so is most
of the video that you use on Instagram
on Facebook
it's just audio or it's just a video
with no sound like because a lot of
times you don't even click like listen
you know I'm saying and so what I'm
interested is how can I use amp to tell
a story in an email in a video format or
like all these other hacks like that
that's incredibly interesting to me I
think there's something there with that
the thing that we've been doing with sin
Fox that we've been building in is
there's kind of like two major
components that I think are lacking an
email so number one is how do you build
in like what the hustle and morning brew
hobb which is building referrals so
we've basically built that in so anyone
can have their own referral engine
within emails that was a huge pain in
the ass for us I know so we built it and
it works and I'm doing it on ok so if
you got a sin fox.com slash Noah you can
see how it looks or sign up for yourself
and it's built in for free I think the
second thing that we're observing so
what everyone wants is like how do I
grow my audience and how do I send
consistent emails because if you're not
sending something weekly you get
forgotten and in this age of attention
we're all fighting for it and so we
built this thing called weekly
newsletter template or week I think
they're called branding it's smart
campaigns and so the idea there is that
we suck in all of your social
information
we look at what's most popular and then
we basically just like we recommend like
hey here's the three things that you
should email your audience this week and
so that's what I do every Wednesday I
just pull my two of my favorite things
and one of someone else's to try to
spread joy and love and build
relationship with people I don't know
yet
how many people are working on sin Fox I
think there's two developers one
designer David is the GM maybe like six
so hey you see Hey long obviously you
saw that so for those who don't know hey
calm it's a new email service it's
pretty neat
I don't know if it's gonna be big but I
definitely I think it's cool that they
are trying that I think I think it
actually will be big but that's the
irrelevant what that company did it
started by 37signals they have a team of
like 50 people and they make money
through Basecamp I think right that's
their main thing and they've used all
they've used all those profits to fund
hey which I don't know how many
engineers they had on that probably a
lot actually it's pretty robust already
at my company what I'm trying to do
we're taking all of our profits and
we're launching more stuff
how are you figuring out how much are
your profit to allocate to these side
projects like send fax and like these
new products so the way that we've
approached it recently is a little bit
more structured look away that the
question that we ask is basically two
things one can we make our money back
within 18 months 18 months so will we
make break-even money back sick 18
months and secondly is it at least a
seven-figure decision so is it at least
if it's not a seven-figure opportunity
we won't do it the reality is the
majority of the money is best spent into
whatever is making the most me from a
capitalist standpoint some of that time
stuff the short term versus long term
and so with sin Fox right now the number
we made our money back immediately
because there's only one developer
part-time and one GM and then as it
started becoming more profitable it was
like alright well let's keep it let's
make sure it's a seven-figure business
and now we're focusing on because we
know it's an opportunity we're saying
how do we get this to be a you know 150
100 million dollar business or whatever
yeah go we're more focused right now on
building our goal there is active
audience so I think one thing with
company metrics is
how do you line your customer success to
your company metric success of your
company Northstar so percent Fox right
now we're at a million active audience
meaning of all of our subscribers we
reach a million active customers through
them and so if we can grow that number
to three million that's our goal this
year then all of our customers is more
successful and then we will be
subsequently more successful so how long
has it been how long have you had people
working on it for about two years
I mean what's fascinating at this just
is a quick side note Sam is that there's
a debate internally not debate but
there's discussion internally that if we
would have spent all the money and time
that we built on sin Fox and King sumo
and Hall drop and meet fam and all the
things we've done just on appSumo the
main thing would it have been a hundred
million dollar business today and their
likelihood is yeah well that's why I'm
asking these things says I'm going
through the same process for I'm like
man I got this cash cow and a lot of
people listening they also have the same
thing where they have these companies
but like we're [__] degenerates and
we can't not make [__] well our
strengths our greatest strengths are
generally our greatest weaknesses so our
greatest strengths for I don't know I
won't speak for you my greater strength
is igniting like I go and start somethin
and I'm like really quick and I'm really
fast my greatest weakness is is like
consistency I always think of it as like
oh I'm a great igniter but I'm not a
great consistent source of fuel and so
you have to find that balance of who is
your fuel so for me Amon is fuel David
over at Sand Fox is fuel and then I can
go focus on the igniting part and I
think that's where you can find success
in life which is what are you [__]
amazing at just do that stuff and it's
hard because we feel guilty or we feel
weak and but it is finding the people
that I can compliment you on those
others there's other sides but take it
another example like like the to my to
my ferret examples that everyone knows
is Netflix and Amazon
how many revenue streams does Netflix
have a lot no [__] one what the
Netflix has one monthly subscription no
Netflix yeah but I'm saying Netflix is
worth two hundred billion dollars from
one $9.99 a month subscription so Amazon
on the other hand is worth a trillion
and they've got in terms of significant
revenue streams probly like three or
four and so I
think there's many different ways of
eating a Reese's Peanut Butter Cup I
think you have to kind of figure it out
for yourself what style of business so
for me with with mine I literally I
thought about this this morning might
might my ambitions and enjoyment and
fulfillment come from like promoting
dope stuff which we do in appSumo
sharing what I'm learning while doing
that which is happening on YouTube and
my podcast
no kicking presents a podcast and then
three making things that I want for
myself which is sin Fox and I'm like can
I just do this till I die or maybe I'll
do this so if I can live forever and I
think that's what we're all we're all
striving for so Sean is joining us now
Sean just got out of a can you say where
you were Sean something more important
than this depends what this is gonna air
but but yeah I was yeah I got pulled
into something very interesting but I
will share probably from now got it okay
so uh tteyuu [__] man right now I
know so we're talking to Noah about well
you heard a bunch of different stuff no
can I ask you I did a pod recently where
I talked about delegating and hiring
like a CEO and general managers can I've
learned how to do this through reading a
few books I learned how to do this from
talking a David Howser who were friends
with I learned how to do it through
talking indirectly like learning from
you on how to do it like I would talk to
a mint I would talk to you a little bit
about it I talked to Neville what was
your process like for doing that because
you have three or four how many GM's you
have or whatever you call them I think
there's three GM's right now so there's
Hall drop
there's appSumo and then there's a send
Fox David does send Fox and King sumo I
think what's actually interesting taking
a step back how many CEOs do you think
there are an Amazon CEO title or job
people who were CEOs and their own
businesses that are now running
divisions of Amazon yeah exactly
and so the people that want to start
their own businesses if you can figure
out how to and align their incentives
and their motivation within your
business is how you create a trillion
dollar business and so this
examples of this by the way there's
Alibaba rocket internet has done this
wonderfully it sounds like you're doing
it well who else has done it well Amazon
has done it well there's way more where
they cut a bit of a company I'm obsessed
with his coke coke family the Koch
Industries they've done that okok I
always call it [__] but I get corrected
fit it's coke who cares just call them
rich the old white fox no I don't know
their [__] but III think in terms of
delegation leadership I actually think
one of my superpowers is just like
observations of greatness so here's
something it's like [__] cares about
no I think what I would do is a listener
and this is what I still do this day I'm
almost 14 I still do this any time you
notice anything impressive reach out to
the person that's it
and over your lifetime figure out how
the [__] do I get around that guy or
girl and I think that will lead you to
an easier six chances of greatness
because it's a lot harder to like go out
and try to like date and find people
just from the ground up it's much easier
if you're like man like you know the
people I worked at Facebook honestly the
best ever literally the best ever and so
it's like oh [__] any in figure out
I haven't able to keep around him
because we had a falling out obviously
but it's like alright how do I be you
have more of that
so like Garrett Garrett's the lead
developer on sin Fox
he built a wordpress plugin that i
bought for like a hundred dollars like
six seven years ago and then I said hey
can I pay you like 25 30 bucks an hour
to fix it and he was so impressive and
he did it for a year and I told Chad my
business friend I was like dude this guy
is [__] fire and I was like we just
need to hire them full time to let him
do whatever he wants and pain whatever
he wants and it's pretty much what we've
done now he works and send Fox and his
output is remarkable and so I think with
GM's and things like that
I'd say ultimately it's like you want to
find the people that blow you away but
those people basically you want the
people who want to run their own
businesses and then two things you want
to give them a challenging goal and then
you wanna give him some boundaries and
then leave him alone and that's the
simplest and most complicated thing to
do can you elaborate on that more
because so I've hired a president of my
company and it's pretty great because
like I get just all the [__] I don't
want to do he likes to do so it works
out well where I struggle is I still
like get into it
get into his way I'm like hey this sucks
you need to fix it this way this way
this way in this way are you doing that
with your people so let me correct you
they're not my people the people who you
work with yeah I think that's a big
difference
and I know it might sound like oh it's
no but I think I never see employees and
ever say it's mine
is there the technicality do I own more
of the business yeah but I think if you
want people to be leaders they have to
lead and they can't ask for permission
to do it you know a lot of times one of
my favorite lines that I've been saying
in the company lately is people ask me
something I'm like who's in charge I say
this a lot I probably say this at least
once a day my who's in charge they're
like me I'm like yeah damn Rand it's you
don't [__] look at me I don't know
and so I think the more that you the way
I've been looking at myself lately with
the team as where's my excellence and
where can I do me the best job of
coaching and I hate when I heard that
because when I've heard that I'm like
what are they coaching and so let me be
specific so with Dork like I've hired a
team of four people to help build out my
brand and to help spread the message of
overcoming fear and starting businesses
and they're these these people went
through the gauntlet to get the job I'm
clear on where they want to go I'm very
clear on where they personally want to
go and so my job is to help them get
what they want and it's got like the gym
run roam quote if I can help them get
what they want I can get what I want and
so I think I learned this when I got
rejected from Microsoft as a job I had
an internship and you know any intern
you get the job guaranteed you know
about that most times when you intern
you get the job your dude I was like the
one of the few that didn't get it it's
like damn I'm an underdog man I'm still
[__] fighting and but I did learn
something in the job interview that I
never forgotten he's like here's the
best way to lead I'm like tell me in
best way to coach he's like you give him
the football you tell him where the end
zone is you say hey here's the
boundaries to get to the end zone how
you want to scores up to you and I think
what I've learned really well over the
past two years is I don't you don't want
to be a seagull you know seagull theory
no I'm coming we're just chirping at
them yeah you come in [__] and fly away
I was doing a lot of seagull theory for
for a few years did you coin that or is
that a thing I mean that your with it
your phrase yeah all right cool well I
didn't I don't want to be [__] on
people and flying away I think it's like
how do you lean in sheryl sandberg style
and step in to these challenges and be
because I think what I always admire is
solution thinking right like am i coming
and complaining and am I being more
problems when I bring more solutions so
in turn anyways in terms of coaching
like with a man who's running a sumo
especially lately I feel like more of an
advisor in a very effective way and I
think it's a really fine line because
you don't resent man so Amy wants to do
this one thing recently and I'm like do
I just let him do everything and resent
it like oh [__] you man I totally
disagree with you
or do I say no Ayman do this thing you
must do it my [__] way it's the Noah
Kagan way my dad used to say this one
little kid he's like my way or the
highway
I was like dude I am eight years old
like I don't know what you want for me
and I don't think you could be either
way of those I think it needs to be
somewhere in the middle where I don't
want to feel resent it I don't
resentment towards Ayman I don't want it
to be a dictator because then the the
the the worst thing I think you could do
is is it hiring someone is demotivate
them that is probably like one of the
dirtiest things you could ever do to
anyone is like demote and I've done that
twice to a man and Chad and they both
said it to me and I felt really bad
about it I felt really like I I don't
want them working for me I don't want
them I want them waking up thinking
about it and loving it which is what you
want from a lot of people in the team
and so I think with Eamon ultimately
it's saying like how can I like a lot of
times we have goals he has boundaries
budgets and then the question I ask is
how can I be most helpful and so really
kind of coming from that approach
because at the end of the day if he's
driving the results I don't give a [__]
how he plays the game at the end of the
day as long as the scores looking good
it's within the boundaries I think yes
I'm a student at the moment first what's
up Noah everybody for joining late I've
been following your blog for a long time
I remember you you wrote a bunch of [__]
that was like you know I walked away
from a hundred million bucks or whatever
it was I don't walk away I got fired but
yes yeah you know my million-dollar
mistake or whatever it was
but I and I've pointed to a bunch of
your tools and so I just want to pause
for a second say one of the ways I got
good at marketing is by stealing your
[__] and if somebody out there wants to
get good at marketing especially content
marketing go read the stuff about how
you built mint and you know just how you
built your own personal brand just go
observe the meta of what you were doing
look at some of the spreadsheets that
you linked out that's actually pretty
useful and there's like a fine line
usually between like I always have this
like big skepticism when somebody spends
so much of their time telling me how to
do something I'm like well how much of
that time much of your time are you
actually spending doing that thing are
you even are you one of those people who
you get rich teaching other people to be
rich type of thing and you know the
thing I liked about you and and a few
others that we revote for on this
podcast is know there's some people who
actually have done it they've actually
grown [__] from scratch to scale several
times they felt they probably fallen
over and failed a couple times but they
just like to talk they like to share and
they like the feedback loop of sharing
out that knowledge and those experiences
and they're legit and so I would say
like go back go to the archive I don't
know I haven't read any of your new
stuff but go read the archive the og
[__] because it was really good
thanks broad yeah I mean I think one of
the things I'm doing recently in terms
of marketing I think overall you know
when I fill out my fellow applications
like I was filling out I'm signed up for
relationship therapy start next week
she's like what's my occupation and I
always write engineer because that's
what I always dreamed of being but I'm
not I don't think I'm smart enough so I
faced it this when I was filling it out
I deleted that and I was like marketer
marketers can always seems like a
therapy starts here you wrote engineer
you're not an engineer what let's don't
forget to relationship so anyways I
think what I've accepted it's not that
I've ever been a marketer I've just I'm
a promoter of greatness and I'm looking
for it and I'm sharing it and I'm
exploring it in myself I think the thing
that I've done recently that it's a simp
it's marketing 101 is with my youtube
that's that's been like our big focus so
I think the two three there's a few
things in marketing I'll say three
things that I think are simplest
simplest you know on some real-world but
number one how about just singular goal
Facebook did it apps to Macomb has done
it and I think with even Riesling with
my dork
world and helping people overcome fear
and start businesses I'm kind of like
having a bunch of goals I'm like here's
our tick-tock goal here's our Instagram
goal here's our email list goal here's
our organic traffic oh here's this I'm
like what is our most important goal and
as I just even pick one for some period
of time and so I think I'm coming to
that realization like let's just pick
YouTube and just be okay with that and
guess what
that'll rise all other ships so don't be
ignoring the ignorant of those other
ones but just focus on one second thing
is that as I was doing a lot of this
content recently which has gotten me
really fulfilled and it's it feels good
feels great is youtuber okay dork calm
mostly YouTube mostly in YouTube world
the second thing that's been most
critical and this is really hard because
everyone does says they do this or wants
to do this but doesn't who who is my
audience who is the audience that I
really want to be helping and
communicate with because on one hand I
want to I want to connect with like
nine-figure CEOs is in ten figure CEOs
and you know I actually don't think is a
lot of content of how do you go from
seven to eight or eight to nine and I
can share how we do it but that audience
is really small and they don't really
know as much help and so we've realized
like our audience is dudes 25 to 40 that
have tried to start a business that
haven't been accessible that are afraid
of failing and need a little bit of help
and so I think the second part of
marketing that I've gotten revisiting is
Who am I really trying to talk to and
what are the words so like here's some
words that we didn't identify that our
audience resonates with rat race freedom
so I'm like really all right
self-doubt so those are some of the
things that I'm thinking about in the
third part that we're we're thing
anything that's applicable for every
businesses what is your unique strategy
of success like so with that we have two
parts one what's our core messages that
we're this is our unique like bread and
butter that you will notice I wear a
meat about this and he's like what did
that you have so many messages just pick
three so I was like all right challenges
to overcome fear million dollar weekend
and behind the scenes of an eight-figure
company that's the three that we're
gonna do and that's it and then the
second part is they say that again so
those three are the three what does
recently let's take a step back so one
what's your goal pick one goal number
two who is your customer number three
what is your core messages that people
know you for so for me those are the
three that I'm gonna be known for
challenges which I always tell people do
the coffee challenge which is take it
ask for 10% off when you buy coffee
you're gonna be afraid you're gonna
learn about yourself and you're gonna
grow secondly is behind the scenes of a
need for your company so like how do you
like that there's not a lot of people
that have that experience and I can do
that and the third part is how do you
actually get a million dollar business
or $100 you know a million dollar
business start in a weekend which I've
done many many times and I can share
which is unique and then the the last
part of this marketing equation that I
think I'm exploring and revisiting
around all these things is what is my
unique strategy or what is my strategy
of doing that I think where I've been
very successful is I just do a lot of
stuff and eventually something works but
I think I will be even more successful
slowing down being a little more
thoughtful with these things and so our
unique strategy lately has been do the
fast stuff but on lower risk items so
basically tweet and Instagram and
LinkedIn post [__] everything like
throw it all out there unlimitedly
and then based on what works a lot
aligning to our core messages that's
what will go deeper and that's what will
write a blog post about that's what will
do an interview about that's what we
will do a YouTube video about and so is
just having a higher likelihood of
homeruns and how would you hi Shawn the
mic like you yeah you really feel you're
almost 40 I'm sir I look and feel 32 but
I'd say I'm I'm about in physicality in
our society 38 and that physicality in
our whatever traditions of 38 okay cool
years I am 32 and I look and feel 38 so
you do look 30 a bro I'm trying to go
the other way so and I would love so so
if you were 21 again 21 no network no
name brand you're starting up from
scratch and you don't have to go the
same pathway you went I'm curious you
know if you had the luxury of picking
any path now that you know of so many
more paths than you probably knew about
when you were 21 what path would you go
down honestly I think I'd copy my path
which would be what so you're 21 what do
you do I'll tell you exactly what I did
I didn't know what the [__] to do so I
wouldn't tried a bunch of stuff out to
figure out
what to do I think the only I think one
question is what Delta would I have
chosen and I'll tell you exactly what
that was
so at 21 I didn't know I didn't know
what a BS was I got it got it from
Berkley I was like Oh Bachelor so has
this cool
everyone kind of follows a stream right
like when you graduate from college
which I think less and less is becoming
important and once I go get a job go to
Intel go to wherever and I was like okay
I guess that's what everyone's doing but
I've always wanted to start my own
company I didn't know what to do and so
I think the two things that I did really
well when I had that day job at Intel
was I use that as my investor and the
two things I'd recommend is that I
started a lot of businesses so if you're
like I don't have any idea two things
you can do one go to San Fox comm and
start a newsletter and send an email
once a week for 365 days or for 52 weeks
that's number one or number two go on
YouTube take the rhein holiday challenge
and post a video on YouTube for 30 days
start there the second thing that I did
is that I connected with people very
aggressively and I asked anyone I knew
for anyone that they knew that was
really smart
that's how I met Tim Ferriss that's how
I met Warren Hoffman dave McClure James
Hong Max Levchin ramit sethi I basically
put on events
I hosted lunches I organized conferences
I didn't know anyone but I wanted to
bring smart people together so if you
don't know any smart people find one
smart person say hey you should meet
this smart person and then just go and
hang out with both of them guy and
growing guess what you coulda done zoom
if you're in remote country or if you
don't have any connections I think one
of the ones I've really observed lately
every person I've hired that's been the
most impressive has done two things
they've offered something for free to a
value that I've wanted and they did it
without asking and those people live in
the most impressive and guess what now
they're like hey I want to meet this
person I want to do this thing I want to
grow here and like that most of them are
now working with me and so I think I
would have that was something very early
on I was very aggressive on meeting
people and just trying to build my brand
in terms of career I think the two thing
one thing I did very well is I was
really great about following my
curiosity and things I was really
excited about so I really loved Facebook
and I really loved mint and I was like
I'll do whatever it takes to work there
um I think the only difference I would
have chosen is find someone 10 to 20
years ahead of me that I think is doing
the things I would would like to do in
10 to 20 years and be obsessed or
aggressive in figuring out how to make
them excited to want to be a part of my
life so I had one guy dug her she was my
boss at Facebook and it didn't really
work out as well for as a mentorship but
it's nice because like you can say oh
that's how you do a relationship oh
that's how you do a career and it'll
shortcut it you just have to figure out
the real most important thing is how do
you get them to give a [__] about you
and the best way to do that is help them
with whatever things they're working on
so you want to hear something crazy
Shawn I don't know if you know this but
I don't know if Noah knows it but I
launched my I created my so my company
which is a it's an okay company it's
been good for me it started because Noah
had a blog post about organizing
conferences and I was like I what was it
called it was called like how I made how
I made 90k hosting a conference or
something was that it Noah mm-hmm I made
a coordination conferences because I I
didn't know I was gonna make money to
him yeah so I saw that and I was like
well I had a book club at the time and I
was like well I didn't mean I've been
hosting these meetups but I don't make
any money from it I should like make
money off this thing and so I started my
come
and he have made millions of dollars
personally off conferences because of
that blog post and more importantly or
maybe not more importantly I've met I
met actually all three people in this
call and most of my friends and
co-workers do because of that blog post
because of that blog post I met Neville
because of that blog post Neville the
best man my wedding I met because of
that Katrina so so what you're
describing of what you would do and how
basically you described like hosting
events and which is similar in the same
vein as posting content I did the same
thing and it made me millions of dollars
and I met all my best friends that way
awesome I mean I think the only other
thing that I was doing at the time that
I think everyone should do so number one
build your brand in some way even if
you're not trying to be a personal brand
I think practicing writing is a skill
you can use in sales you can use a
development you can use in design you
can use it almost literally forever
I think the connections very valuable
literally probably the reason I'm a
multimillionaire is because I've been
able to meet and help people and connect
people connecting and meeting but the
third thing was that I was starting a
lot of businesses and I think what's
beautiful is if especially earlier in
your life your cost of living is sodium
low and my cost of living is still damn
low because I'm I haven't grown up in
some ways and I'm maturing in certain
ways that it's so low that you should
take a lot of risk very early on in
trying a lot of things out so I like
when I was working to Intel I was doing
this college consulting I did a thing
called ninja card comm I was putting on
these conferences that I charged for and
then I was working at mint I started
doing the Facebook apps like Italy's
games and I started making a lot of
money but now I was working at morning I
was working on weekends I was working at
lunches we're working at nights I was
working I was kept going and I kept
trying a lot and eventually after
probably two and a half three years good
you know four and three or three years
later my side hustle finally became my
main hustle did any of those like I have
we actually have a good friend encore I
don't know if you know I'm Sean but me
and no I do who did the same thing about
the online he did like the Facebook apps
and Facebook games and when I think of
that [__] I'm like dude that is just
some scam e get-rich-quick [__] is that
an accurate assessment of what those
were and because I was a little bit I
was too young to be doing that [__] in
2000 in
ten or whatever became popular I wasn't
interested in the internet was that is
that an accurate assessment of what
those were uh I think what's interesting
is like how do you become a part I think
what's weren't shown about the Facebook
games besides whatever people spam or
not spam it's like how do you be around
the tidal waves so I think where I've
been very fortunate and lucky is that my
career either I'm an ambulance chaser or
I'm like a visionary or maybe a little
bit of both where like I was in the
Facebook game world I was in personal
finance world I was in social networking
world I was in SAS world with sumo I was
in e-commerce world with you know some
of a Shopify and lately I'm back in the
content world and I think what's been
the beautiful part about that you know
in an AB Summa but in the software world
which has been amazing I think the
amazing part about that is that it's
opened up a world where my life is more
rich not rich even monetarily just like
rich like fill it fulfilling because of
all these really cool people I've gotten
to connect with like I got to meet this
guy Nick Nieman and I'm gonna talk with
him on Friday about videos and then I've
got to meet this guy Xavier Mercedes who
lives in Austin who came over and showed
me how lighting like okay look let's
switch lighting here let's switch
lighting here and I think what's amazing
is try to figure out which category is
gonna either be big or which category
you're interested in and then how to
interject yourself in that conversation
so you're like well no I'm not a
developer I don't have any commerce
products to start guess what
start a [__] YouTube channel
reviewing this products or start an
Instagram account where each day you
just post hey here's my favorite
ecommerce probably here's why or start a
newsletter on Sun Fox calm like hey
here's my weekly e-commerce product of
the week and email that company saying
hey I just promoted you this week one of
the easiest things that anyone
especially early on can do is flatter
people Jett legitimately don't just
[__] and because it's obvious but
just flatter hey I love your stuff
that's an easy way to open the door and
then do what you can to start helping
people and so I think what I've been
lucky and intentional about what am i
curious about and what's becoming more
popular and how can i connect with
people that are inspiring me I would
also say like sama I wouldn't call those
that that Facebook game era because
there's a whole bunch of other friends
that we have that started or like kind
of caught their first big wave on when
Facebook platform opened up like the
very first episode of podcasts Uli
so he caught his big wave was he made a
Facebook app called superlatives and it
was about you know saying which of your
friends most likely to end up in jail or
goofy stuff like that or you know I know
some of the Lowell apps guys listen to
this and they were yeah they were you
know the fastest growing company in the
world at the time probably like you know
oh my god you know you'd launch a
product and get to ten million users in
a day and that just breaks your mental
model of the world and so I think two
things hey you're right that the people
who go there were the type of people
that sniffed out interesting spaces
before they're proven out so if you're
that type of person you're gonna end up
in a lot of those types of situations
the second is you get this crash course
on hyper growth and marketing in a way
that's like you can't learn like this
guy who the guy who sold tbh to Facebook
recently oh yeah yeah this thing out
yesterday that was like it was good
first-time social app founder he's like
oh we're gonna build a platform for
intellectual conversations it's like you
know I get 23 users and five percent
retention and then he's like by the
fifth year that same founders like
alright let's just have people vote on
who's hot and it's like result 10
million users 40% retention it's like
you know it's very true it's like the
only way to really ever get good is by
putting yourself out there so when
you're saying go start a YouTube channel
or somebody goes and has to build a
Facebook app and you see that the apps
that grow are the ones that tap into
people's core needs like they want to
know about their friends they want to
take quizzes about themselves and learn
you know goofy personality quizzes and
it's the person on the sidelines who's
like oh all that stuff's dumb and what
they're missing is that they don't sort
of figure out you know at the end of the
day you get rewarded for giving people
what they want not what you want people
to want and then the second thing is
that if you really want to get good at
anything you got to be in like the eye
of the storm and these new platforms are
these areas where there's a lot of
growth a lot of action happening that's
where you sharpen your skills so you you
know you might not have ever made money
off the Facebook games right like you
got a bunch of great users and now I
made I made money well you might have
made money I think the question is if he
I think you need to pick are you trying
to make money trying to learn because I
think sometimes when you're young you're
like well I wouldn't make money off this
person looks like well maybe there's a
lot more long-term dividends by just
trying to focus on what you can learn
but the work but also wouldn't you say
like I've seen this in my life sounds
like you were in the same work it's when
you're trying to make money that you end
up learning because you're trying to do
something hard and you have to learn the
hard way like what actually works and
what doesn't the first is if you just
say I want to learn a lot of times
people take a very sort of passive or
intellectual approach to it now that's
different than saying I want to make
money so I take this job at Intel that
pays me a guaranteed six figures or
whatever it is you may not learn the
most doing that path because you're not
actually challenging yourself in the
same way but what I think the two things
I would highlight there is a I think
there's passion or interest or curiosity
and then I think there's opportunity and
I think I've I've chased opportunities
to make money which have been fleeting
they've been profitable but fleeting and
I think when you're in your 20s you
should do those frankly you should just
do the things that are like hot and
exciting if you think want to make money
and then in your 30s you start
reflecting more like wow mortality is
real what's really important and I think
you'll come back to finding how do I
work on problems and things that I want
created for in my own world and for you
that's what that's helping people sort
of overcome their fears to start
businesses that there's a one step
removed from that no it's exactly that
it's like I want to be on the ground
level helping people overcome fears
start businesses and marketing in
businesses I love seeing the underdog
succeed I love seen like this guy ali
abdullah is a popular youtuber I love
seeing companies like meat fox who got
promoted appSumo and now they have a
business around it or a phone wagon is a
popular once a day for doing phone calls
and that guy Ali he's great he's a I
think he listens podcast but he's a
doctor right he's a doctor youtuber or
is that yeah he's so I mean he's so
impressive he's like you know people
like I don't have enough time this guy's
a full time professional doctor making
3d high quality YouTube videos every
week and he engages an audience and he's
put you know it's just very genuine I
really enjoy
can you spell his name a li a B D a al
you know and I think it's interesting is
that you have to think about on the
reverse of that how do you become
someone that people want to meet how do
you make things or do things that others
want to connect with and I think we're
like oh I'll just do stuff and hope for
what happens this guy looks amazing I
just love dough like I just did a quick
google did oh you did is just dope I
love this guy he's just like I found him
because
he blogged like hey here's some cool
[__] I found this week and our podcast
was in it and so I was like okay who's
this guy who's giving us a shout and
then I checked out his YouTube channel
and I was like wow this guy's amazing
well I think that's something that even
in my newsletter every week now we have
an S section where we prune other people
I think the more that you can go and
this is one of the things it's like
stupid obvious but no one does it it's
like go help a bunch of other people and
there's a good chance that you'll be
able to connect and get a lot of things
you want like well I heard a quote
yesterday and I got to go in four
minutes guys
the quote that I heard yesterday that
was like really powerful to me was uh it
was like your rewards in life will be
exact proportion to your contribution
that's interesting I don't know if it's
true though because I feel like I you
can definitely make money by like some
[__] Facebook like a fleeting app
you know what I mean but I definitely
think it's a way to live by but can can
I bring something up within the last
three minutes so it four weeks ago or
three weeks ago Sean told me about a
book called happy body and I told I was
with Neville Noah last week or two weeks
ago and I was like yeah I Sean told me
about this book I'm gonna buy it and
Neville was like oh I have it upstairs
let me go get it for you he gave it to
me then he gave it and then Noah was
like wait what's this book and I think
he added a buying I've been doing those
exercises in that book I feel great have
you guys been doing that so basically
just got the book yesterday so I have no
idea what you're talking oh my god
basically I'm what I'm realizing and is
I on this podcast said I had scoliosis
and I had like 30 or 40 people reach out
to me say they also have scoliosis and
so then I started doing this book to
help fix it it's been awesome I've my
back feels so much better you get edges
your back feel better Sean I never had
back pain so I what it's not my I wasn't
doing it for that I just like I read the
philosophy and I was like oh I vibe with
this like this makes sense to me I don't
feel like I'm being sold to I think this
this seems like one of those like
fundamental truths about the way your
body works and how you should like sort
of tune it and so I started to like it
but I haven't been like doing all of
those actually I've been swimming a
bunch but like I haven't been doing
those exercises in
but yeah if your back hurts give it a
shot you know like back pain is one of
those like you know quality-of-life
ruiners if you have it and so you know
you just gotta try [__] everything if
you have back pain well Noah was talking
about getting older and trying to feel
younger and before this podcast he took
his shirt off and showed me his body and
that's what we do that's what real
friends do but golly this thing has
totally made a difference we aren't
getting I'm not getting pay to say this
but that shit's awesome right so no
let's ask you then what is been the the
best either decision purchase change
like that has lifted your quality of
life on a day-to-day basis that you've
done you know in the that comes to mind
recent memory take a minute you could
think about it yeah I think they're
probably about I'd say three and then I
got a jump off so number one buying my
Tesla I think it's not about the Tesla
but I think it's about I think I we're
conditioned that like in materialism is
evil and I think it's more about is
there ways that we could use money to
make our lives better so I think that's
been really powerful for me to like wow
really enjoy something versus getting
the cheaper like me I like Miatas and
having me out in the backyard but it's
like nice have something amazing and I
wonder what else in my life gonna have
that would be amazing
and that I can also be amazing because I
think it's something to say about what
is your stuff say about you the second
thing I would think about is journaling
right so I've been using Bare app I
think one of the you guys asked for
three business opportunites one of them
is technology advisor there's so much
new tech new cameras new everything like
I think you can go make a lot of money
coaching people well but they're bare
dot app or bear app notes
I really enjoyed every literally Journal
five days a week and it's been really
helpful to understand myself better and
learn my interests and motivations and
fears and all this stuff and then that
those two have definitely been powerful
I'm trying to think of the third thing
that's really and I think the third
thing that for me is really changed my
life is observing where I'm living and
how much my space affects my energy so
I've been renting Airbnb ease and I'm
gonna be moving because I'm like you
know there's something there about your
space and how much it can impact you
professionally and personally guys I
gotta go I love you guys
Thank You Sean let's stay on but Noah
let's come back again and actually talk
about some business stuff because that's
awesome I also wanna do the other thing
thank you have a good day guys you too
yeah thanks Sean but you want to talk
about anything Noah said Sean you know a
lot of it was really relevant to me
because I think the things he's talking
about like the thing he spent like I
don't know 15 years doing now he's
building up this audience this like
putting out great content that's gonna
help people and like distills down his
wisdom like okay I learned something too
active me trying to teach it to somebody
else will help me learn it better I
think that's the vibe I get from him
that's what I want to do that's what I
find in most enjoyable my life anyways
so personally I thought that stuff was
interesting if you're not trying to be a
content creator I don't know how useful
that part will be for people but
honestly these are pretty universal like
just like tactics to get [__] done and
get [__] out there and like be an action
person and so yeah I like I like his
message around being an action person I
wish we've gone into ideas cuz I think
he's a kind of idea starter like he said
and so maybe what we do is we have them
come on and we do just ideas that we
could even release this as a double
episode you know sort of ideas plus
interview to our sort of session well
he's coming he's moving to San Francisco
for a month I think next week he's
staying at Andrew Chen's house and we
definitely could do that I one thing
here I'll actually bring up something
that he mentioned that is not related
any that self-help stuff which I enjoyed
but what kind of so he talked about his
space and buying a nice car so I think I
just spent three weeks in living in
Austin I think I'm gonna give up my
place in San Francisco I'm gonna spend
four to eight weeks in different cities
and see what happens so I'm gonna buy a
car I don't know what type of car I
should buy but I'm gonna buy a nice car
and I'm gonna drive all over the country
that's great
and so to the listeners but I want to
ask your opinion on that but also to the
listeners if you want to rent my
apartment I'll give it to you for six
months it's 4k a month I live in Glen
Park it's a lovely neighborhood
and it's furnished and I have a gym here
a home gym a really nice one so you
message me on Twitter if you want to
rent it otherwise I'm gonna give it up
and I don't want to sighs dude you
should charge a premium this is rents
sleeping sambars bed for 8km unthe
actually you know get that good good
yeah no there is no pre maybe I should
[__] I just blew my yeah - except for
guys who's willing to except for I know
I I wasn't gonna make money on it I just
you just cover the expenses I Austin is
amazing more people should I don't know
what sometimes I'm Michael it's over
there so a couple years ago I made a
decision to do something similar where I
was like I was sitting in San Francisco
but I was like why am I just here all
the time like life is so big the world
is so big and so so I told my girlfriend
at the time I was like let's go you know
now my wife but at the time we were just
dating I think and I was like let's go
live in South America for the next six
weeks and like I'll just work from there
but like let's just go pick a cool city
that we are not gonna live in long term
and I want to move but I want to go live
there and I was like wait a minute I can
live there without moving and the way
that San Francisco works is like an
arbitrage where you can Airbnb your
house or your apartment and you could
make more you could literally live for
free somewhere else in the world you
know get free vacation so that's what I
did it went for five or six weeks we
lived in Buenos Aires Argentina and and
we just lived there like a local not
like exact year what year was this expat
but it was better than crap wasn't a
vacation it wasn't like go sightsee take
a bunch of photos and leave after five
days it was like okay we're gonna live
here like what's the coffee shop we
should go to how do we get groceries and
like that was just a way better
experience I was like I'm gonna do this
every year but then one year was like oh
we're getting married and then I had a
kid now I don't know what I'm gonna do
it
so wait but you did do it I did do it
for one year and I plan to do it again
this year now that my my child is a
little bit older I think we can go do it
now cuz she's almost a year old so I'll
do it again so my logic is I'm only
going to go to places I could drive to
for two reasons one Corona and two
my dog who I considered part of my
family I he's old and I would not want
to leave him behind and I don't know if
you can bring a dog you could probably
bring a dog to some European countries
but like in a lot of places they have
like a three-week quarantine you could
get to Canada you could get to Mexico
that's cool well so I would move to
Mexico City in a heartbeat no have you
been there I've never been but everybody
who I know says the same thing it's like
amazing it's amazing like I remember I
was there when Trump was just getting
elected and he was talking about the
wall and I was in like a hipster
neighborhood and I asked my barber I go
what do you think about this trunk I
tell my wall he goes I don't give a [__]
about what he says like I want he goes
yeah build the wall that will keep you
guys or coveted this is amazing here do
not try to go to America and I was like
oh man you've just broken all these
stupid stereotypes I've had in my head
thank you so and and so yeah they're
gonna need a wall to keep me out of
Mexico City because that place is lovely
it's oh I would totally want to live
there the Mexicans were awesome people
I love the neighborhoods but Corona I'm
nervous about Corona at the moment
yeah Corona and before this it was
what's it called Zika which I can people
didn't really care about but Zika
scariest [__] especially if you're like
we were gonna have a kid we knew that
and Zika like basically you could become
a carrier for a year or so and pass it
to your baby so that was like a scary
this that's what that killed it one year
and now Corona it's like I don't know
what I'm gonna do it but I'm gonna do it
I think I'm gonna do Canada because I
trust the Canadians around Corona where
Vancouver Vancouver or somewhere remote
who knows cuz like but like why would
you do remote Canada when it's like the
same [__] it's like Montana is that I
also don't I also would go to Montana
Manset Montana it's cool too but you
know I don't I don't mind that that's a
change of pace what car should I buy
should I do this in a f-150 truck should
I do this in a Subaru that I like put
off-road tires on what should I buy I
thought about at rasuluh well that
doesn't come out till 2020 water and I
want to leave in August you could do you
could do that as a Tesla SUV or you
could do the f-150 I think that would be
hilarious although that's kind of
cramped and not the not the most ideal
y know an f-150 is for
you can get a four-door but a cyber or
Tesla would be [__] horrible wouldn't
it for a 3,000 mile trip why cuz like
wouldn't you have to pull over every
every 300 miles for an hour the
superchargers are pretty fast and it
goes like I think the the new ones are
whatever girl like 600 miles or
something crazy it's interesting maybe I
would do that yeah do it definitely do
it in something that is not your usual
well that's what Noah said that inspired
me I was like I'm not gonna
penny pitch I'm gonna buy the nice [__]
that I want waiting for you just waiting
for somebody to be like you know what's
cool buying cool [__] that's right that
resonated with me too I'm always doing
like penny pitching [__] so I need to
step that up you want to go over
anything else I have a bunch of ideas
that I added to the thing but I feel
like we should just do like an episode
about it like a full episode about those
ideas so I think we should keep this one
kind of Noah and then yeah I have a
bunch but it would be like an hour okay
I have a bunch too they range from
interactive email to I have a bunch of
ideas around privacy stuff that
fascinate me a ton and Korona stuff
someone's got to create the organic
label but for like is your restaurant
Korona clean oh yeah like the it's like
the you know the health score but like
this is difficult at around
Korona hygiene yeah that's I'm gonna
bring up what are you gonna bring up
okay I'm just gonna read you some of my
quick notes that I had here one it's
called Scott Galloway being super wrong
another one I know exactly what you're
going with that and I'm very interested
another one is scams that I found
interesting and I have four examples of
scams that I found interesting
another one is WikiLeaks for creeps
because Chris D'Elia turned out to be a
creep and then another one is how the
37signals guys are marketing their new
thing hey calm I think it's pretty
interesting how they're going about that
and then I have a bunch of startup ideas
that are around one is around baseball
cards one's around yeah we got a bunch
of ideas so we have we got a lot too
great I am interested in all those
particularly the Scott Galloway one and
the Hakam thing which I think is
actually gonna be a huge business I just
downloaded it have you used it no all
right I'll tell you if you didn't like
superhuman may not like this either but
I just
thumbs up or thumbs down I'm like 10
minutes into the onboarding but I'm also
like thumbs down so far but I really
like those guys so I'm like just let me
try it actually I wouldn't say I've
given it a fair shake yet but onboarding
so far I'm not sold I'm in the same boat
but I understand why many people will
like it right okay we should we should
jet here
[Music]
you